okay okay so it is my pleasure to
welcome counselors to the meeting of the
I'll start again actually I lost my way
already Jim it's gonna be a long night
yes my pleasure to welcome counselors to
the April meeting of council a special
meeting in in many ways it's termed an
ordinary meeting but it's special
because of the way that we're
interacting today which is something
we've never ever done before and that's
via zoom technology it's a bit of a
learning curve for everyone including
myself but it's a so I just asked
counselors to the to be gentle with the
chair as we go through and we'll try and
get through what is a reasonably lengthy
conversation this afternoon with some
pretty weighty subjects but before we
get into the meeting is such now I just
like to acknowledge why we are meeting
like this and and pay tribute to those
people whether we know them or not but
those people that are putting their
lives on the line to make sure that
ordinary New Zealanders can have a good
and and fruitful life including
themselves in harm's way of the
coronavirus something that even a month
ago three weeks ago none of us can
probably even pronounce or understand
what it was all of a sudden that's
become parents and in the language of
the day and we're all sort of hanging
out every lunchtime to just hear how how
the progress has happened over the last
24 years for ours in terms of new people
coming along and potential deaths and my
heart goes out to those families that
have had members that have passed away
because of that virus and we wish them
all the very best but particularly for
those locally for the health workers the
civil defense workers the the police and
the ambulance that like said that the
social agencies like women's refuge and
those ones going above and beyond and on
counsels behalf I say thank you to the
if we got any apologies today I don't
think we're here I think we've got a
fool master so we'll just move on into
the council agenda for real and first
item up is declaration of the conflicts
of interest the council may have always
regard to items on the agenda and
conflicts that haven't already been
declared by councillors is there
anything that anybody needs to to clear
at this point in time there's not if
something becomes obvious during the
meeting there nots leave it up to your
discretion councillors and hopefully
we'll declare that as we go along okay
so moving on to our three which is the
confirmation of the minutes and reports
confirmation of the minutes of the
ordinary meaning of council held on
Tuesday 10 March would somebody like to
move that that be seen as a true and
correct record of that meeting and can I
[Music]
can move that okay signify it councillor
host:it is there any alteration to that
record does not put that motion all
those in favor say aye
all right against the motion is carried
Thank You counselors I guess but it'll
take a few minutes to get into the
rhythm of things but at the moment I can
can see hands raised so we'll go with
that at the moment but if it gets tricky
I'll ask you to raise your hands
electronically so I do get to see
everybody that wants to see so moving on
to the next set of minutes which is the
confirmations and minutes of the
extraordinary meeting council held
Monday 23 match but somebody like to
move that be seen as a true and correct
look at that meeting
Stuart conclude of a seconder for that
nibble thank you is there any alteration
required to that record does not put the
motion all those in favor please say all
right all right
thank the motion is carried Thank You
counselors Britt Nicholas ask a question
of the chief executive you raised up on
that item mm-hmm um just with the change
in legislation since we
it allowing electronic meetings to be
powerful
I just just wonder about that the merits
or otherwise of having a quorum remain
it may still be appropriate but it's
just been interesting and going the
Chico's it may have on that yeah Jimmy's
if you want to make a comment on it if
thank you worship and cars the house did
yes look at the the quorum of to really
is something that becomes automated as
soon as you have a committee of council
so the council established an emergency
committee principally because of moving
into level four environment and by
dentally Emergency Committee
despite the council having that
committee comprised of every elect a
member it does actually give you the
internment not that if the user of
having a quorum of to I'm not not
unclear that resolution was it was it
was the the committee was to be in place
until alertly before was uplifted and
then I daresay that situation we were
reviewed but the quorum is an automated
provision and the local governor fishel
information and meetings at any
committee of the council has a quorum of
just two members as distinct from when
it's the four council it has to be at
least half the members okay you
comfortable with that counselor I said
you are that's great and that emergency
committee will stay in place until level
four wins doctor level three or two okay
moving on the entire limb for which is
urgent wait business is there any urgent
late business counselors wish to table
at this point in time I'm not aware of
any okay thank you
and I don't five the financial report
and we have a report from our accountant
Donna and I think it's reasonably
straightforward but Donna do you want to
just talk us through this please
certainly you worship and I just like to
firstly point out a couple of things on
the front page of the report I have
incorrectly put in a figure where it
says the total revenue is lower than
budget by five hundred and twenty six
thousand dollars it shouldn't affect
state total revenue as higher than
budget by an $85,000 my apologies for
getting that one incorrect and I'd also
just like to note that since the date of
this financial report the world has
fundamentally changed and therefore we
will see some changes to our figures
through the coming months
so um total revenue is higher than
budget by eighty-five thousand dollars
and with total revenue expenses higher
the budget by see one hundred forty
three thousand dollars in an overall six
hundred and fifty seven thousand dollars
over budget in ZTA recoveries are behind
by five hundred and twenty six thousand
dollars and this is the main driver
behind this variance their higher
depreciation in insurance costs along
with the regulatory department continue
to impact on the budgets as well and
flooding response expenses are still
coming in and are not included and the
reported expenditure is the funding
options are still being investigated and
I'm happy to answer any questions
these ETA timing issue so a lot of it's
actually true to the pyramid bridge and
whereas there is command a budget so and
with regard to the flooding costs we
feel comfortable got those covered so at
the moment I'm working through the
actual welfare costs which are 100%
covered the insurance companies have
been and discussions with us for some
other items and we are also just and
Russians with the National Emergency
Management Agency and regards to
government funding for some of our costs
like the landfill okay thank you so
Stuart and then Brit not complete
inventories we've got envy industrial
have spare parts or replacement parts
well I didn't think we are we do we do
so we'd have because of the type of
items that are required to run the part
the plant we actually have to have them
in stock because it does take a lot of
time to actually bring them in from
overseas I believe just on that point
mr. chief executive to sort of give a
good counselor as a reminder of just the
situation was regarding the ownership
and the costs of that thank you worship
the it's it's called quite rightly the
envy em industrial hub in the EM have a
lot of rights that they don't extend to
ownership it was paid for by nvm nvm
looked after and paid for and owns the
pipeline leading to the industrial hub
the hub itself is council owned and
operated the operations are fully funded
by Indian courtesy of a a waste water
agreement and nvm also has under the
agreement rights of to a degree of
exclusivity in terms of using that
particular facility NZ could be expand
for another user potentially I say but
that would be the subject of a separate
consultation conversation within the end
but ownership on yes it certainly and
the council's box yeah hey thanks Donna
that's a it's a pretty comprehensive
report so I appreciate that I just got
two questions my first one relates to
the regulatory department
being 161,000 unfavorable is in
addressed and hooked up in air air Karen
and your plan budgets that you're
working on in terms of address or is it
something we're going to is an ongoing
issue so most of it has been picked up
so a lot of its to do with the change in
the management of the planning
department so it's bringing and a new
cleaning manager which wasn't and this
is in your plan and also I think an
adjustment with just the whole team so I
believe them having an administrator as
well as having a actual planning officer
here as well so they've all being picked
up and the annual plan going forward
thank you my second question relates to
suspense account I have a personal dread
obsoletes accounts heard that
expenditure I realize is uncertainty
about was funding but I'd really be in
favor of in future being reported than
that P&L there's an expense maybe it's a
separate line item because yeah perils
of suspense accounts are probably pretty
well known to you as well but it's just
my personal view but it would be more
comfortable for me really as as they're
going to be addressed quickly in terms
of clearing a bit suspense account or is
that something that we're going to have
to wait some time for in terms of its er
its funding so I'm hopeful that quite a
lot of what's currently in there will be
getting address quite quickly but of
course there are a few unknowns and
especially we to put those costs as well
so there's all sorts of different costs
that might not have an appropriate place
to put just you okay so could we perhaps
agree on a time line that it's
appropriate the hold and suspense before
it does have the P&L is next piece yes
so yeah cool it's an ability in terms of
an accrual and not at this point sorry
it is in the balance sheet and it does
go through and the that's we are all
this visits expense accounts I help our
and the beyond the shape I'll leave that
with you thinking thank goodness I three
heroship I dunno I'm just wondering do
you have any idea whether the lot down
it's going to have a negative or a
positive impact on objects and I'm
thinking in terms of parks and reserves
in roading and not not having their work
out there on the road in that one could
have it there I'm not actually too short
to be perfectly honest I don't know if
there's been any work being carried out
on roading isn't an emergency or for
safety they still could be getting
carried on there'll be a question for
Pierce enduring but I don't think that
those areas would necessarily affect the
budget too much in the long term it
would be more our revenue collection
side through the pulse in the regulatory
functions that we might see a downturn
on yeah thanks thanks Don and thanks
Dennis things good good question I
wonder if you can see that perhaps give
us a bit of more about a global view of
where he sees what we're currently going
through every now and likely early
impact on council yeah thank you worship
I think the as Donna has correctly
alluded to it's really the revenue side
of the equation that I see the the
pressure points in the cost as well but
more to do with the fact that I can see
Riga tree for example even if we do come
out of level four on changing next
Wednesday for example I don't think we
only be springing back to life and pre
covered nineteen developmental
conditions both and
terms of building consents and resorts
consents and then you've got the the
pool where a decent amount of revenue is
relied upon to opposite the rate pair
input and the pool there's no guarantee
that the pool will be able to open level
3 the Prime Minister of course is going
to be making announcements tomorrow
afternoon about what little 3 might mean
and it will be obviously watched with
interest and listen to of interest by
you know I mean for us it's the Kim
family open the poll if not under level
3 that situation will need to be
considered and the overall impact it may
be having on the council's business the
likes of PACs moszer's was our born
fundamentally it's the staff have been
redeploy where we can there's no revenue
expenditure hits apart from the fact
that the service isn't being delivered
gives Gardens wage in them and his grass
here's the autumn flush effect and well
as in surveys reported men's meetings
look if they can get back to it and
lodge it was suggested that should be
uplifted if now golf courses are being
able to be maintained I would argue
quite violently I would think about
packs materials and change in MO and
should be able to be done though there
are I think it's growing pockets of
discomfort and obviously we're making
what are watching brief in terms of
rating income people's ability to pay
and what the council may need to things
of policies and processes that that she
facilitates some ease in which those
things can be managed and anyone
requiring some transitional arrangements
can access them so that those type of
measures don't it being thought about
and know that will flow through and to
some some reports and some traditions
and the coming weeks to Council
see then I guess the Glynnis good
question Willem dick and deadly have an
effect it's probably too early to tell
just what that effect is going to be but
Peter and Ian just from our passion
reserves perspective and from a writing
perspective this is there anything you
want to add to those comments for your
honor system pretty much just carrying
on as business as usual to soonduk seen
as far as the funding goes but we know
sort of thing nothing held back from us
I mean our funding still available we'll
just catch up there we have carry out
when we come out of us and yes thank you
your worship
look the the parks and reserves activity
vaults there is some long grass around
some weeds and some of the garden plots
we are quietly confident that when we
see a level three situation occurring
that we will be able to get back as
Steve rightly pointed out for some more
operators and cabs and things like that
that are reasonably secure but still
we'll get some of the work caught up on
we're confident that that'll that'll
occur shortly okay thank you right we're
still on the financial reporter there
any other questions or queries or
comments John you just one question was
going back to the NBN and how we
refunded by MBM for their capital or is
it classes running costs and just passed
on running cost at the end of the year
and so my understanding is that it's all
included and the operating expenditure
which is organized for a mess department
through a wash up at the end of the year
the man do you make any comment to that
you think you worship yeah I have to
just tell me that we are claiming the
tree carrying cost but the trade waste
agreement is
and full cost recovery but I just have
to confirm around those and patrique
carrying costs thank you so Rahman sorry
I missed your hand yep you worship um a
good report Donna thank you I possibly
just comment it was not as good to see
that they clean the ear loans are still
being uplifted which is right and I was
just wondering back to the pool complete
except you in your idea of the loss of
income over maybe a say like a month of
non-use unfortunately I have not looked
under their chest yet but as something
that I can look forward and true for you
for the next report I put together thank
you okay any other questions queries
would somebody like to move the
recommendations in possibly can signal
it you can still go on thank you
all right against the motion was carried
Thank You counsel so moving on then to
item 6 which is from our recreation
manager in sofa just with regard to
future use of 67 Wigan Street adjacent
to the a MP grants for you yes thinking
you worship this has really just come
about with the letter received for the
council just prior to the end of last
financial year and December around the
applications that had come and we're
going to the provincial growth fund so
that didn't find favor there so we were
left in the situation of having to two
things firstly report that decision back
to you the council and secondly then
flag what we thought the future could be
for the site and then to give the
council some options around gauging its
thinking on how it saw that
site going forward and with the
recommendation also including an
opportunity for the canvassing of
community views around that as well but
I'm happy to take questions on that your
worship
okay not specifically worship only I
think I don't think councillors need to
be pressured into coming up with a hard
and fast decision tonight the key word
here is EPS guidance and indicative
direction and you know potentially if
the councillors need more time they
should feel free to take that time we
just want to bring it forward to you as
it's an ongoing issue of some
uncertainty that it would be nice at
some point in time to get him to cloudy
around and it was great just on the on
the basis that it was seen as a good
investment of time without a particular
in mind and yeah but thank you so open
for discussion and I've got hand I've
got bread yeah no thanks for the report
I just think the world's fundamentally
changed since since the council asked
for feedback on this I think just in the
current economic climate with the
uncertainty out there you know we don't
know where unemployment healing tourism
opportunities community funders ability
of funder I think we should just just
sit tight for a moment there's a show a
community that we you know we're just
recognizing where we're at right now
with Aria right now in grace we could
just bring this up again in terms of
canvassing the community you know maybe
review in six months time just to see
how that my own father died I just I'm
just reluctant to go out there with some
inspirational ideas that make money
right now I guess from what I'm hearing
you're saying you're suggesting we
should probably note the report and then
we're the chemist and the community
consider what actually might be
appropriate a girl cannot tell you where
they see Doug and Nikki you've got to
ends up
so don't do you want to if think she
worshiped totally agree with counsel
host it's it's the the aspirations of
some in the community maybe they spin
towards festering of it I believe it
needs to be canvassed towards the entire
community also whatever we do with it
it's got to be a standalone project
there has to be all the ongoing costs
for careers and maintenance employment
whatever it is in you it can't come the
other great part it's got to be so the
actual wording of the recommendations of
the bleed pretty pretty spot is to be
determined in the future on a
case-by-case we don't jump we just just
go slowly on this one okay thank you
your worship yes I thoroughly agree the
moment it wouldn't be appropriate to to
put this out the consultation I agree
that it needs to be put on the back
burner it is something that we can get
out and dust off in the future when
finances and the economy looks a little
bit better in there's more prospects for
it so I think we should just sit on the
lead job just a couple thoughts for the
set of reservations about them the
second part we're offense within the
boundaries and limitations of the
reserve date 1977 what does that mean as
it venus locked in under reserved
limitations or as a pre for Neos and the
second question I'd like to put has been
any more thought to subdivision of land
against of to Road boundaries for
housing I notice a contaminated site
there is work that could be done to
prove that the outside edges are not
contaminated and there could be sort of
13 to 15 sections subdivide it off
leaving to an architect to use offer for
eight years that could be sold and rent
and rates could be collected from those
in future he's going to answer that but
to my knowledge there hasn't been any
way
done on those items that you have raised
and I am aware that previous owners had
looked at subdivision in that area and I
think the Wow I did see a subdivision
plan on the area so yes you there are
areas that can be used for residential
absolutely council hasn't hasn't gone
down their track as far as I'm aware
Steve yeah I think she worshiped in
terms of the first Christian counts to
get on the ecology reserves act
classification does limit your ability
it becomes a reserve an ear for is only
available for recreational type use bet
something the council may or may not
want to do and but that's not a
recommendation that's before you tonight
it's just something to perhaps think
about to be here I think the council
when we water them to speak there's
probably going to be used more for some
future recreational pursuit then
intensive development for residential
purposes as woods the city in his
counselor gone on has acknowledged the
property does have limitations and
regard to not only continue the land but
areas that you can't build on because
there were tunnels under the ground that
were filled in with rubble but there's
not to say that's not impossible but
like a lot of things it would also be
the question as to how that come about
what the council's role if any would be
and and so at this point in time all
those potential uses still be exist if
the economy improved or these are
direction from the community the council
should take a certain stance so but I
think we need to and acknowledge that I
couldn't see intensive residential
development and they given the number of
limitations but a lightly approached
development with
allotments may make it seem to be
possible but like a lot of things happy
you know okay so my sense is that the
council of the mind that we should note
in receives a report and when and if
they arise opportunities should be
considered on from Europe at the time is
that something like to move that way
don't thank you dogs signify their
counselor who said thank you
is there any discussion there's not
emotion all those in favor please say
aye
so those against the motion no Rosie ham
please okay motion is carried
unanimously
cute see we'll move on then to item
seven and we have a report from material
community board from Monday the 16th of
March seems like a different world but
it's the afore receipt and ratification
of recommendations that are contained at
school just this is Susan do you want to
make any comment on the report thank you
worship now there's nothing okay all
right any councils got any questions or
queries Doug thanks true I'm here
worship just a query on the kalam
Terrace walkway it was recommended that
the funding considerations Timothy
Proctor 20,000 prayer so the long-term
plan would be $10,000 just a query do we
still have PD workers there will PD very
ancient people that used to go around
and do community service and do we do we
do can we still tap into that as we used
it I don't know I think we you know in
you want to make a comment
thank you your worship you look directly
and in terms of the PD workers we used
to get a lot of help in different areas
off the reserves from the PD Department
Donnell Moore Park was one particular
recipient that we used to get a lot of
help with but at the moment we've
probably for the last year 15 months
we've had very little and it's hard to
get them actually on site there is some
that do come to the ANP grounds and
staff they're utilized some of their
help from time to time but it's it's
certainly no when like it what it used
to be where you would have a couple of
teams two or three times a week on a
certain site and that has really been
ruled out as an option for working in
that particular site for those reasons
they just okay any other questions or
comments on the material community board
report nibel as a community board member
you have any thoughts you want to share
no I'm right your worship I was a little
bit late in attending the meeting but
everything seemed to be okay
it was just one or two queries about the
the matera X subbing poll we're going to
once we get back to and swing of things
again we're gonna have a bit of a
workshop and discuss what we want to
bring forward to Council and regards
that building etc looking at looking at
the council's guidelines you know what
councillors they want to do in the
future with that
etc so that was about the only main
thing and of course err ongoing projects
I've come to a bit of a hold at the
moment but we're still in in working on
the sidelines at sideline with those
those two projects that we want to try
and push forward so thank you and
everyone else in mind do you want to
move the two recommendations there that
it be received and mutations within well
I'll move that your worship don't was so
you can do for that
and I'm seeking applicants counsel
hosted thank you and all those in favor
please say aye
thanks the motion is carried thank you
do you wish to yeah raised oh sorry
it was pretty worship it was a question
about the potential for the old railway
station building with co19 and the
extended hold up of being able to do
anything if this building at the moment
how does that place a community Ford as
a whole for being able to reach there
different project destinations which
lobbied arts which live adults that you
wish is that contained in the report so
there's a question outside the report
and it's probably a little bit early to
to make any comment on that one I
would've thought generally it's it's
gonna be pretty hard to just pick will
where the priorities and we're the work
that needs to be done is done what
things
your worship can I'd you it was just I
think Nick you might have been looking
at the section 5 under general and I had
brought out the discussion about the
land purchase for the shipping of the
material railway station to their
particular place there is the sir and
yes so as I said before everything sort
of put on hold that currently at the
moment until such time as everything
comes comes comes together and comes
right we're in no rush at the moment to
to push this issue along everyone's in
the same boat so we're just holding for
standing in line just like everybody
else
Glynnis did you have a question I just I
just had a you worship I just like to
say to nibble that I know that I'm dark
looking for work for some of the
employees because of the downturn and
tourism would it could be worth
approaching them um just to see if they
did have any people that they put your
way
yeah thanks please as I said I've been
been in discussion with Elmo but you
know a lot we've been in discussion over
the last two or three weeks and I better
hear projects and we're having a
whatever sit down as soon as everything
comes right and a debrief get together
have a plan of action to go forward and
that's one of the possibilities that
would that would it be right to pursue
with you later on
thanks clean us thank you and I'm sorry
nicking business for missing that Susan
just reminded you'd put that motion used
to be don't sorry
yes thank you right we'll move on then
to item 8 which is six monthly update
this is the first six monthly update
we've had from from great sales in this
format anyway an organization that's
been doing an awful lot to come up to
speed and be in a place where can can
help drive not just this area but the
whole Southland economy and there's
certainly an awful lot there to read and
to to take out but I would have to say
that since this report has been
published then is has been mentioned a
couple of times already the world's
change and their focus is isn't [ __ ] and
totality from a lot of what we're
reading here but really it's about
working in recovery right across the
province particularly in the tourism
side but not just in tourism certainly
business and Jim wall is doing a lot of
work so a lot of focus is going in there
but Steve do you want to talk to the
rule
yeah you say worship like this as it was
put up to you just so you can you can
become familiar with what great south is
about and what it's been doing getting
itself onto a film launching pad but
this is as worship receded like a quaint
insight into history a world that's
we're behind really what I can tell you
though is that there is going to be a
revised statement of intent that will
come our needs to be approved by the
council by the end of this month
I've yet to receive it but it will be
likely part of an extraordinary council
meeting we need to call to have their
approved to keep faith with the
timetabling for what breaks out but it
will be a lot from them what it was
there was a draft prepared pre the
covert 19 lock down that has since been
pushed to one side and and with a an
expectation from the council's their
great South could go back and really
revise it completely to take account of
the tangent of the world we're dealing
with and likely to be focusing a lot
more around business support and a lot
less around tourism juditha tourism as
one industry that is going to take at
some time particularly international
tourism to come right but we can speak
something to emerge in the next coming
days and then that will be before you
for consideration to say within about a
week right okay so this report is open
for discussion if anybody wants to make
any comment thank you you worship I just
noticed the numbers and I know it's
after the horses [ __ ] but they had
692 million dollars down as the total
tourist speed and it's just a pity that
they actually hadn't broken back down to
with a percentage of the domestic market
as I say the horses faltered but in
future maybe that might that would also
be good for us to be able to see to miss
and eventually international tourism so
we can see if there's a steady increase
in that you know you were looking at
their budget it's heavily weighted
towards increasing tourism increasing
budget business development and devine
so it's it's a completely new day and I
would think now that possibly if there's
going to be any increase in tourism that
may come from domestic tourism people
through the North looking to have a bit
of an adventure in the south on but I
think it will be very conservative times
for great selfie and but they do have
conserve less it some people of ability
so you know like I saw look at the pull
through a little they were thinking you
worship I just say that they had
prepared for annoying conferences and
resulting in seven being secured you
wouldn't have any dates have we missed
some or not or is there any that we may
be able to help them out with that
aspect
do you know over they internal
conferences or they are overseas ones
coming in it was ever they're just going
on the activity of each other were
mainly domestic Consing as opposed to
things coming from overseas or the soon
that bits the sign but I think that the
conference market is pretty much out of
bounds at the moment anyway and probably
will be that way until I would say well
into the later part of this year and so
yeah the report is completely other date
the expectations of councils across the
province I think that's going to be
quite different has been in the past
discussion going on that's great south
over the last
ten days working them to get them to
revise what their plans will be and what
their intent for the next you will be
and I think no doubt that they
understand the challenges that what they
understand their need for the in to
perform and perform well forward to
seeing what that intend looks like when
it's written down okay and anybody else
want to make a comment there no okay
we'll move on then
so something like to move that it be
received please
we've moved significantly nurse thank
you it's not with the motion all those
in favor please say aye
the motion is carried
okay we'll move on into item nine and it
is great the grass subcommittee report
here from the admin manager committee
hit on the banaji attached consider a
number of grants and there's some
recommendations here for us to to
consider any comment Susan from that one
on the admin side and not from me you
wish it would be to the two bit
subcommittee councillor grant worship
not very good report written by she call
exactly what was said basically we had
three annual submitters say from the set
up for the newly officials Ward's in the
terrace school bus transport the
swimming lessons and we have a new
submitter multiplayer video gaming so as
you can see the report says it all
basically so
before we give discussion orientation
so put a movie of the movie that would
be received and the recommendations
contained within a port be ratified as a
seconder for that mayor council host it
thank you
while it's open for discussion and
elaboration there any our council hosted
it thinks you were so just want to pick
up a point that was made last time
around the Youth Council hitting some
and defunding or some funding I realized
immigrants committee issue but I think
it's probably a very good point that
this is a very central item something
one that many of us wouldn't understand
but probably just an example where we
could impair the Youth Council to to
have some someone caught and the
community just a comment yes no so the
idea and there well that one is a very
Youth Center issues a little bit there
any other kind or councillor grant sorry
Douglas sakes you worship yeah it was it
was brought to my teaching last year by
a couple of the youth counselors who are
no longer there but they actually I
don't know if they asked for a budget
they they put forward that could we
operate off a budget because we don't
know what a budget it's and I don't know
exactly I wasn't in the meeting but this
is what I was told by by Tunisian and me
and I thought she was a great idea give
them a budget let the music budget for
the year work out what you want to do
it's it's perfect for this sort of thing
but also it was it would have been
perfect for this this last application
is council hosted see thanks to it ok
and cancel read to don't see you Linda
yeah thank you worship Susan will
probably know more about this than most
of us but
maybe two years ago the Youth Council
actually did work with James Ward and
hosting an event and the old roundtable
Hall and it was very successful and he's
very very good with the kids
and maybe that's the thing with during
Youth Week that they could pick up and
run with and help him just introduce it
to other other children and the area
Glennis comment all right now yeah okay
I thought James's project was very
worthwhile and I do know now that the
Lisa a new hurinui is working with James
and I think it could look into the
future I think it couldn't work out
quite well yeah
and personally I think that the
enthusiasm and the energy that that
particular individual brings is
something that we need to harness and
use in our community as much as we
possibly can i I know it's it's a it's
an area that I would just shy away from
completely I don't know anything about
it don't want to know but I know that
that's an area where those individuals
particularly used with challenge flock
to relate to and we need to be making
sure that we've got as good a
connections we possibly can with them
I take the point that yes is raised with
regard to fuckingly who know anything
with it and I'm hopeful that there will
be a long-term relationship and it could
could go and number different directions
the other council hosting yeah just just
wonder sometime in the future we asked a
report from the TV executive just a
missing the opportunity to grant the
Youth Council summer budget and how that
may not correct
yes you get it no oh I'm not I'm new I'm
just finding a good ass for a report
from the chief executive sometime in the
future on on their issue of granting a
budget to the Youth Council how they may
operate what would be appropriate but
good idea and there's almost two issues
here it really isn't it this the the
recommendations we're considering but
side to that is an input into into
particular issues or opportunities like
this from counsel and and how they are
situated to take advantage of those and
did I see somebody else's I knew ya
think he worship yes during that meeting
in and as I see it that I had said that
there was no current money set aside for
the for the Youth Council and Aaron
counselor that grant could possibly be
involved in this and in asking the
questions to the youth what sort of
money that they may require and help
help perhaps Steve with a a report to
bring back to Council and we can make us
in sessions room from there okay so is
there any other comment we've got a
mover and a seconder for the report the
suggestion that paper be compiled and by
the chief executive to come back to
Council the Youth Council the motion is
carried
Thank You councils right pretty much
brings us to the end of the open section
of the committee's I would just make
note it's not doesn't form part of this
meeting but came out with the agendas or
close to the agendas was the Community
Services bulletin and again while it was
compiled
at a different time then we're in now
it's just great to see the work that's
going on in this community and I love it
being driven by by council staff and so
just say thank you for all those
particular inputs the work that council
staff do interesting survey there on the
library so all of that is available for
anybody that wants to peruse it on the
council website on June is that right
yes it is right but just before we close
the open session of the meeting is there
anybody wants to make any comment on
anything that is in the community
bulletin okay right so then move into
Part B of the council I'll I'll move
that council move into to Part B to
confirm and consider the various items
that we have listed there do I'm signify
that Oh speak of it was a senior to
counsel Bolger wasn't further police say
all right guys the motion is carried
Thank You counselors so we now in Part B